they're just chanting death to america
but they seem friendly at the same time
it's utterly bizarre
it's refreshing to hear a kinder gentler
death to america
[Applause]
[Applause]
right
happy monday or as joe biden calls it
and you thought jimmy carter sucked
fall of kabul is imminent as the taliban
enters the city the imminent fall of
kabul the
fall
of kabul the taliban has now entered the
city the fall of kabul as the taliban
completes its takeover of afghanistan
armed fighters broadcast live from
inside the presidential palace
i blame those pesky white supremacists
now you'd figure we'd have a plan for
this but this is the most botched pull
out since hunter knocked up that
stripper
20 years billions of dollars and no plan
or maybe we had a plan but joe left them
in the men's room at coldstone creamery
boy this crowd's quiet
jesus oh now you're laughing wake up
people i know it's monday but
i mean if we knew this would happen the
moment we left what gives i'm not here
to say i told you so because i never did
i was like most everyone else spending
the last decade forgetting afghanistan
existed and watching the bachelor which
is either a testament to the
effectiveness of our military to keep
things under control or my very short
attention span so the taliban sets its
sights on kabul which is good news for
lori lightfoot her city no longer is the
most dangerous one on the planet
but what were our priorities while this
war went on for decades for us at home
it was bad cops bad tweets bad
combustible engines bad pronouns
yes the cdc reminds us it's pregnant
people instead of mobs i'm so glad we
won that battle
meanwhile our armed forces uh put out
highly polished recruitment ads that
ticked all the intersectional boxes
we're not sure how to win wars but at
least if we lose them we won't be able
to blame just old white men
we also learned that our military
leaders assigned left-wing anti-racist
tomes to our troops so at least the
afghan military can hate america as much
as we're supposed to
think about it 20 years preparing for
this moment
and we're as lost as joe biden trying to
find a white house entrance
i mean there are thousands of american
citizens still in afghanistan you'd
think we'd have evacuated them sooner
yet president biden has lost more face
than during his facelift
[Laughter]
deliberately awkward phrasing
seriously where is the leadership has
anyone called the white house
hi this is the office of president joe
biden my desk is currently away from me
and i don't have a cell phone yet if you
need assistance press one and you'll get
kamala harris now uh what button do i
hit
that's weird
hi this is the office of vice president
kamala harris i'm currently out of the
office but not in europe
if you need to speak to someone press
one for gen saki or leave a message at
the sound of the cackle
[Laughter]
okay
hi this is jen
saki i can't come to the phone right now
i'm doing a um photo um shoot for vogue
and then vanity fair teen vogue then um
baby vogue
if you need to speak to someone press
one for the um catering department
what the hell's going on here
are you with brian stelter i'm currently
off to lunch
please leave a message
any ideas for dessert after the beep or
press one for fred flintstone
[Music]
fitting
so think about it as we watched
terrorist waltz into power what were we
doing well we obsessed over white
supremacists in january 6th with our
commander-in-chief yelling never mind
that bin laden look alike with the
rocket launcher it's this white guy
wearing face paint and a viking hat that
we gotta eliminate
check out this graphic about potential
terror threats from the dhs
it's aged as well as stephen tyler's
face
you wonder why kabul fell faster than
joe biden walking up a flight of stairs
how about viewing opposition to mass
mandates as the same threat as
terrorists
talk about making all threats relative
including your relatives yeah your aunt
wants your aunt who wants election
transparency is no different than people
who flew planes into american buildings
now when your bag goes through x-ray
screening at the airport the tsa won't
be looking for bombs they'll be looking
for trump t-shirts
so your uncle who won't get vast until
it's fda approved well he'll be the
first terrorist waterboarded while being
made to wear a surgical mask
notice how that graphic is really clear
on who the first two threats are they're
basically trump voters but that third
one seems intentionally vague so terror
attacks could happen on 9 11 and
religious holidays who might do that
i'll give you a hint it won't be the oak
ridge boys
it's got to suck to be an actual
terrorist not getting adequate credit if
the word terrorism were any more watered
down it would be one of cat's drinks
from a concerned bartender
twitter was allowing the taliban to
actually tweet while at the same time
banning conservatives at this point does
anyone born in the 90s remember what
terror is its slogan is literally never
forget
but we did instead of being prepped for
this we handled it like a college frosh
freshman knowing the finals were three
months away i'll just cram the night
before and figure it out then so as
taliban assumes control without a hiccup
we should at least see part of the
reason why
it's in that chart which shifted the
threat from one group to another and
played down the mad men of the past
islamic terrorists attacked our country
but there was a guy who wore a viking
helmet in the state capital same
difference right
january 6 was worse than 9 11 because
it's continued to rip our country apart
january 6 was in effect a second kind of
civil war the worst attack on our
democracy since the civil war the worst
attack on our democracy since the civil
war the most serious threat to our
democracy since the civil war
you see how easy we forgot about the
taliban
and made ourselves the bad guys to feed
a narrative that legacy media agreed
with we weren't fighting a war in
afghanistan we were fighting it here in
america against ourselves black versus
white conservative versus liberal gay
versus straight trans versus non-trans
legal versus illegal cop versus
criminals mask versus masculists backs
versus non-vax
we took our eye off the ball and when
you do that you strike out in
afghanistan we were caught looking at
ourselves
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guests
freedom is in free and this guest picked
up the tap u.s army combat veteran and
florida congressional candidate corey
mills
his punch lines are harder to find than
people willing to work
writer and comedian joe devito you
probably wrote that
the only things more worn out than his
clothes are his one-liners
the loftusparty.com member founder
michael loftus
and member
she's like a shovel
skinny sharp and caked with dirt fox
news contributor that's him
[Applause]
happy monday everyone all right corey
yeah you're a veteran i i'm i'm willing
to bet that you thought the exit from
afghanistan probably could have gone
better
yeah to say the least
here's the bottom line we
had an actual plan that was based around
a condition-based agreement that was put
under the trump administration
this goes even beyond that though when
we start looking at the ideas that we
thought the nation building was a good
idea that was never the actual intent of
the us military our intent was to go
over there and eliminate you know the
terrorists that were actually
responsible for the 9 11 attack right
that was the reason then it kept going
where it was political football every
president wanted to put their rubber
stamp on it to say that they did
something different so it was mission
creep after mission creep and then bad
intel from generals you know we have too
many mark millies not enough actual
patents right and so we sat and looked
at how this condition-based agreement
would go forward and joe biden
essentially played political optics he
said oh i want to pull out on the
anniversary of 911. well that's now spun
out of control because none of those
conditions were actually approved so now
this becomes actually propaganda for the
taliban for china for russia and for all
those who are going to say here you go
watch the americans will never stick to
their plan and they'll never actually be
here we've lost credibility on the world
stage as a result of this tough yeah you
know uh michael he said mission creep
and i was just thinking of you
yeah that's it it's like we're on a
mission and i'm a creep i see what you
did thank you very much why do you hurt
me
every time because every day that you're
on i tell you to get dressed you know
what i show up looking like a dirt bike
i've been thinking i've been thinking
about this problem and here's what i
need okay a multi-million dollar
contract there you go and a personal
assistant there you go how about this
how about that so could we make that
happen yes tomorrow it'll all be set up
come to my office okay so what do you
make of this i'm making this this is all
on uh that this uh that general uh
millie yeah yeah i don't care about
anything else that happened you had one
job dude this is all on general milly
he's millie like millie vanilli that's
how you remember how to say it like how
millie vanilli pretended to be pop stars
but when showtime came they couldn't do
it yeah that's general milly he looks
like a general he's got the uniform but
he can't do the job
i i could see your brain work shopping
that's not milly it's a lot like millie
vanilla
whack can i connect them together
milly
he's the lip-sync in general it's
perfect also but let's face it and he
thought he was so enlightened oh my
goodness oh yeah i've read books about
this i've read books on woke i've read
books on critical hey how about you
crack a book on winning a war or how to
retreat successfully and i want to say
this publicly like like legit for the
men and women who served in the military
none of this is on you right this is the
in charge you were failed by them yeah i
think um
that opinion too joe if you talk to
anybody in the service it will basically
say exactly that right absolutely they
have to they have to it's um
well but we spent years not thinking
about it that's what i always feel like
our afghanistan muscle was flabby right
yeah it i i always i forgot about them i
looked at the taliban like radiohead
like i hadn't thought about them since
2005. who makes better music almost
every other band
it's going to say taliban taliban maybe
um there are early stuff
yes
and people were wondering
didn't we train the army enough
what a shame they were just weeks away
from finishing the sensitivity training
for the afghan army yeah but now i mean
there's a reason why they call
afghanistan the graveyard of empires so
other people have had their shot um good
luck china yeah you're next up to take
your shot at
trying to rule this lawless region and
now the taliban's out there partying
like it's 14.99 they're gonna have a
great time
and what really bothered me was i i
think we should have approached this the
way i approach dating do what you have
to do declare victory and leave yes
exactly we should have been out of there
five years yeah gotten rid of al qaeda
control the situation and left right
this nation building is ridiculous and i
would have agreed with what the
president said today about how we're not
going to be there forever and all that
stuff i would have agreed with that but
if you look at the way we left there's
no way you can look at that chaos and
say that's the way you wanted to go down
he was telling us just weeks ago that
none of that was going on
his speech was fantastic if it was two
months ago yeah but now it's a straw man
argument it's not about leaving it's
about how you left and he didn't he
didn't even assess how you left he was
saying it's time and he in the the
statement about i don't want it to be an
a a fifth president president's problem
and i thought that was really good but
it doesn't matter because it's the
problem that happened under you
cat uh afghanistan as joe said is the uh
graveyard of empires you are the
graveyard of boyfriends so you
i want to thank you for your
service i thank him every day he's got a
purple heart
enlarged too i will be completely
serious here actually and that we do
need accountability for the people who
are in charge here i don't mean oh what
about trump or bush or obama that's a
distraction from the accountability that
we really need for the people who were
in charge of this my husband when he was
in afghanistan 12 years ago said he knew
that what they were trying to do was
never going to work and he had very
lot less information than people at the
top then 2019 washington post gets the
documents we find out lo and behold they
did know all these guys stopped they
knew and they still kept coming out and
you know giving these rosy
pronouncements of what was going on over
there they're getting promoted they're
sitting at you know the boards of
companies and my husband's been very
upset saying hey you know i agreed that
i would have given my life for this
country and all these people at the top
cared more about their power and the
money in their pockets than they cared
about his life i mean he lost him into
west point lost four classmates in
afghanistan alone um there needs to be
an investigation if there would have
been any failure
i mean a trillion dollars equipping and
training these people and it all falls
apart so quickly like this yes this were
anything else there would have been
investigation accountability but because
just the military industrial complex
props everything up props everything up
they're getting away with it we're
talking about huge amount of money
talking about human lives and there's no
actual responsibility it's disgusting
you know what it is the analogy is the
building in miami that yes i said that
on the 5. did you yes was i there yes oh
wow
i said if a building fell down like this
quickly and people died
then there would be an investigation up
next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else